hi my name is shushan i did my bachelors
of technology when i was studying in
south korea i realized the growth of
digital business is immense and since
then i had a strong inclination towards
digital marketing so i made up my mind
to take up digital marketing specialist
program at simply learn to kick start my
career when i was still in college soon
after the course i was getting a lot of
job offers and interviews and i got
selected in three companies finally i
decided to join kpmg as an analyst i'm
very grateful to simply learn for
helping me get to where i wanted to be
and creating a strong base for my career
during my internship i felt there was a
gap which i needed to fill that's when i
decided to upscale myself we were taught
a various theoretical concepts in
college but they were very limited in
terms of practical skills uh which were
needed for the job when i decided to
upskill myself i was searching for
various platforms online while there
were a lot of good digital marketing
videos on youtube they were not well
organized therefore i knew i had to find
something that has a good course
structure and expertise along with a
solid recognized brand that's when i
chose simply learn as my upskilling
partner the content is very well
organized and scheduled for learners
like me the course has covered vast
topics from beginners level to expert
level in addition to this uh we also got
a lot of practical exposure from the
live lessons and live sessions projects
which were done under the supervision of
trainers i think the course had
more implementation than just the
theoretical concept considering digital
marketing is all about implementation
since i was fresher directly from
college i did not know technical aspects
of digital marketing neither the
knowledge of profile building and resume
the certification has already helped me
establish myself as subject matter
expert in google analytics in the future
i would like to learn more about
marketing analytics and build my
portfolio for consulting firm
learning does not stop at college it's
progressive
an investment in learning pays the best
interest
[Music]